New York City's police commissioner says
there is a mental health emergency in
his department after that night suicide
by an officer this year Officer Robert s
Chavarria
took his own life on Wednesday this came
a day after another officer suicide Jeff
Pegues has extensively reported on
policing in America and is investigating
this crisis Jeff what do we know good
morning Tony when we spoke to officers
for last week's policing in America
series off-camera they consistently
mentioned depression and PTSD among
officers and the need for more help so
how serious is the crisis consider this
a 2018 study found that nationally
officers are now more likely to die from
suicide than in the line of duty my wife
has been my rock it's been hard Doug but
me son Nick was a New York City police
officer for 14 years he took his own
life
last year we don't know why Nick did
what he did a lot of it had to do with
the stress of the work that things have
seen
the NYPD is seen nine deaths by suicide
this year alone seven since June last
year there were four total police
commissioner James O'Neill it's beyond a
challenge it's a crisis you think okay
this is going to be the last one and
last night I got a phone call and I just
did it it just almost knocked me down I
just took the wind right out of me I
just you know what the hell is going on
here at least 124 officers nationwide
have taken their lives this year in 2017
at least 140 officers died by suicide
compared to 129 who died in the line of
duty departments in Chicago Arizona and
New York are adding more counselors to
deal with the crisis just think about
the cumulative trauma that police
officers are exposed to each and every
day and where how does that manifest
itself we need to change the culture we
need to make sure that our police
officers have access to mental health
care so they can keep themselves well
and through the job that they they want
to do we just have to make sure that
people know the help is out there and
the NYPD is offering counseling in new
ways for officers to seek help
anonymously but a study finds that only
about
three to five percent of police
departments nationwide have the
resources that they need for suicide
prevention President Trump recently
signed a bill to give funding for police
suicide prevention efforts it's really
striking yeah I was gonna say to you
that line of duty deaths now are lower
than suicide isn't that a stunning
number it just shows you the scope of
the problem across the country but you
know I have to say a lot of these police
chiefs they're having a hard time
dealing with this you know how do you
counteract this and how do you get
officers on the beat to admit that
they're having these problems and that
they're potentially in distress I hope
they find a way Jeff thank you very much
if you or someone you know is in crisis
right now contact the National Suicide
Prevention lifeline that is one eight
hundred two seven three eight two five
five